so just take a minute and ask yourself
when was the last time you slap between
six to eight hours when was the last
time you had a deep quality sleep and
woke up feeling refreshed if you're
someone who struggles to get a good
night rest or if you just want to
improve on the quality of your sleep
then watch this video through sleeping
is such a beautiful thing unfortunately
with the fast-paced life nowadays most
of us do not give sleep the priority it
deserves having a good quality rest is
known to help manage your appetite and
also cravings which is linked to weight
loss and to maintain a healthy weight
long term if you don't get enough rest
it can also sabotage your workout plan
because when your body is tired you are
more likely not wanting to do any
exercises and even if you do your
workout your body and your muscles will
recover slower slipping is also known to
promote better mood clearer thinking and
also better work performance so getting
a good quality rest isn't just about
your bedtime routine how you spend your
entire day has a direct impact on your
sleep so I want to be sharing with you
my routine something that has helped me
to get a better quality sleep at night
and I hope that it will inspire you to
love sleep as much as I do
I like to start my morning and sometimes
end my evening with a solid workout this
includes a mixture of strength training
cardio and sometimes even yoga
exercising three to four times weekly
between 45 to 60 minutes we'll have to
improve the quality of your sleep but
remember to avoid exercising three to
four hours before bedtime because it can
actually make it harder for you to fall
asleep
who loves a cup of coffee I get a lot of
my work done from cafes and of course I
do enjoy my cup of flat white however if
I know that it's already late in the
afternoon you know I'll try to be good
and up for her booty instead because I
know that my body is more sensitive to
caffeine having coffee after 2:00 p.m.
would only keep me awake the entire
night so if you're just like me avoid
drinking coffee in the afternoon and go
for a cup of tea instead I like to
either sip on green tea or chamomile tea
if it has been a long and tiring day one
of my ways to wind down is to soak
myself in a warm bath just about 2 to 3
hours before bedtime I'll soak myself
for 20 to 30 minutes it helps to relax
my muscles and also mine a cozy soak
raises the body temperature slightly and
the immediate cool-down period
afterwards relaxes you this natural drop
in body heat will help you to fall
asleep quicker
you
it's breakfast like a king lunch like a
prince and dinner like a pauper that's a
lot of truth in that saying make dinner
your lightest meal and have an early
dinner as much as I can I try to have my
dinner before 8 p.m. and of course I
just love my soup and noodles having a
big ole spicy meal at night will put
your digestive system hard at work this
may cause heartburn or indigestion
which can keep you awake if at all
you're feeling peckish before bedtime
then just go for a small snack and keep
it below 200 calories center oils and
candles helped me to wind down breathe
better fall asleep faster and wake up
feeling refreshed the easiest way is to
buy fragrant candles you can also mix in
a few drops of essential oil with water
and gently miss your pillow before bed
here's a fun fact smells can also
influence your dreams so try out
different scents then make you happy
relax and give you a sweet dream our
body needs time to shift into sleep mode
so one hour before bedtime
put all your electronic devices away
this includes switching off of a TV
laptop iPad and also mobile phones
I am very easily affected by the noise
vibration or even the slightest glow
from my phone
so when I want to get a quality rest I
like to put my phone on airplane mode
one of the most common reasons a lot of
people can fall asleep is because of
their cluttered mind so rather than just
ignoring it I choose to write my
thoughts down and also a list of things
to do the next day this helps me to put
everything into perspective and to clear
my mind off my worries and if there's no
reason for me to be up late I aim to go
to bed at about the same time every
night which is just before midnight I
even get my friends calling me
Cinderella because of my sleeping habits
developing a sleeping schedule will have
to regulate your body's clock and fall
asleep easily you'll also be able to
wake up in the morning at about the same
time without the help of an alarm clock
so when it's time to go to bed go for a
complete blackout even the slightest
amount of ambient light may disturb your
sleep and tell your brains that it's
time to wake up so I like to keep my
room as dark as possible
if you can't seal up all the light
sources in your room then consider using
a comfy eye mask and if you still find
yourself awake choose to lie in bed in a
calm and relaxed position release all
the tension from your body and breathe
deeply for a few rounds to relax the
mind and body you know as much as we
want to aim to get a quality rest at
night remember don't stress yourself out
about it the more you fight it the more
difficult it is to actually get any rest
so just take the time to understand your
body and the triggers that keep you
awake at night and slowly work on that
slipping is such a beautiful thing if
you find that you're not getting enough
rest or if you just want to improve on
the quality of your sleep apply these
tips and I hope that in no time you will
be sleeping like a baby
so what other method has helped you to
get a good night rest do let me know in
the comments below if you find this
video to be helpful remember to like it
and share it as well all the best
you